what did you learn most
from your first nfl draft experience
you know peter
back at the senior bowl ozzie newsome
who's a guy had so much respect for over
the years from baltimore ravens
i saw him one night out to dinner
and he congratulated me on the job and i
said hey guys you got any advice
and he said mike here's the deal
he said having an opinion is a hell of a
lot easier than having to make a
decision
and i gotta tell you peter i learned the
weight of that last night
mike mayok after years of being in the
media now the gm of the oakland raiders
and look peter
when everyone was surprised by the
cleveland feral draft pick at number
four my first thought is hey look we
wouldn't be surprised by it if mike
mayok was still a draft expert he'd been
banging on the cleveland feral drum for
the last three months and the rest of us
would have picked up on it and we'd have
expected him to be taken in the top five
so not having the benefit of mayhawk's
expertise made it harder for the rest of
us to be ready for what mayok was going
to do and look it was a surprise they
took cleveland farrell at number four
you had a great point yesterday they
were hoping that the phone would ring
they believed they could trade down and
still get him the phone didn't ring they
had to take him they got the guy they
wanted and i've got the impression
across the board peter that they got the
guys they wanted
here's the thing with their draft mike i
i i made this point
that you know john gruden is an
impetuous guy
look at this graphic right here and i
want you to look at josh jacobs and
jonathan abram okay
for a month
the the oakland raiders have focused
almost solely on getting those two guys
with the their second two picks
in the first round but
mike mayok was convinced and convinced
john gruden we are not giving up draft
capital to go chase these guys
trust our board trust what we know about
the other teams around us and we know
that we're gonna get those two guys now
it got real hairy because philadelphia
traded up ahead of them as i wrote in my
column they got very nervous that the
eagles who loved josh jacobs were going
up to get them but they didn't and and
just a quick little note that i found
very interesting
right after they take josh jacobs
there's euphoria in the room
and now they're focused on abram because
that's the 24th big now at 27 they have
to wait for two other teams to pick and
make sure they still get this safety
from mississippi state jonathan abram
and they wait a second and all of a
sudden you know mayak starts thinking
man do i want to use a five to go trade
with baltimore at 25 to ensure we get
our guy and gruden is like do it do it
do it
but mayok said no we're going to trust
where we are we're going to trust our
process they did they ended up getting
them
and so i think the moral of the story
here is that they're no longer going to
be
just sprinting and doing all of these
things to build their team just because
it feels good there's going to have to
be a plan and if you lose a guy or two
along the way you do
but i think that's one of the things
that mike mayok has brought to john
gruden a sort of settling down of gruden
that i think is really going to help him
in roster construction yeah i think
that's a great point you bring up peter
because yes i mean john i've been around
him a lot gruden he can be emotional and
make emotional-based decisions at times
mayhawk seems to be the guy to go wait
chill out here this is what makes sense
here let's not go crazy just because of
emotions here and mess up everything you
know for years to come the the oakland
raiders mike mayok did a phenomenal job
they killed the draft their first four
picks are all going to be starting on
their football team the corner they got
trayvon mullen uh at the you know the
40th pick in the second round i thought
he was one of the best man-to-man cover
corners in the draft uh really you could
put the raiders into discussion uh and
this this goes to mike mayak again for
winning the off season when you look at
their free agency and go antonio brown
trent brown you know uh tyrell williams
you know some of the other uh lamarcus
joyner they got uh just brandon marshall
j.j nelson all these players to improve
the roster they have really killed it
now within all that
again i do think at number four with
cleland farrell that was almost that was
almost as much of an overpick as daniel
jones at number six i mean peter they
admitted it in your column basically
that they were hoping the dolphins at 13
or somebody would trade up because they
still thought he would be on the board
but i'm never going to be mad at a team
for taking somebody that they liked and
it really seemed like it was the only
way they could orchestrate getting all
three positions they wanted there in the
first round was to over draft for a
feral at 10 and so i get it and i'm not
going to fault them for that but really
if you're welcome remember remember
remember one year ago yeah on the night
of the on the night of day one of the
draft what did people say when chris
ballard took quentin nelson number six
oh my god you took a guard number six
you overdrafted quentin nelson well
and the moral of the story is if quentin
nelson is a great player and it appears
at least as a rookie that he was yes and
he's going to be then it's not
overpicking if you get a great player no
matter what position he is at four or
six you've done a good job
peter my first thought when i read your
point that no one called the raiders
when they were on the clock at number
four was hey if one of the teams between
six and 17 was hell-bent on drafting
dwayne uh daniel jones they could have
called the raiders and traded up and
gotten them gotten him before the giants
at six they didn't even call do we know
if there were conversations though
beforehand that would have set
parameters of what the raiders were
looking for and then just no one bit or
did they have no conversations
whatsoever at any time with anyone about
moving out of that number four spot
i don't know the answer to that mike
knowing mayok i bet he did have
conversations but
because he's just the ultimate boy scout
he's always going to be prepared but i
can't answer the question the point is
though in that 8 or 10 minute period
they didn't get a single phone call and
that to me
tells you what the market is
uh at that point in the draft and nobody
is so hot for somebody now if quinn and
williams had been there let's say the
jets had taken josh allen at three
and quinn and williams had been there
i'll bet you a lot of money they would
have gotten calls for the fourth pick
then
peter how do you look at you know just
what was your outside look you're just
evaluating mayok and gruden altogether i
mean you know what was your overall
synopsis just about the relationship the
working relationship and how it's all
working
that uh that john gruden really really
needs
mike mayok right you know he was in what
i would call an arranged marriage with
reggie mckenzie you know and he thought
reggie mackenzie was okay but it wasn't
his guy
and so this was totally different chris
this is a guy who i'm just going to read
you one quote from from my column
i've known mike since i was offensive
coordinator at philadelphia in 95. i
work there i see mike i get the head
coaching job in oakland i see mike i go
to tampa i see mike i start broadcasting
i see mike i really got to know mike and
his preparation is no bs
that is what john gruden likes
he likes a sick
football
nerd
that's what mike mayok is right
everybody knows it he is on february
15th he's gonna be up till three o'clock
in the morning looking at the fifth
round corners that's what he does
that's what he loves
john gruden needs that kind of guy he
also needs a little bit of an old school
marm right that is what mike mayok was
to him he said hey settle down settle
down we'll get our guys and gruden
settled down and they got their guys
hey peter my theory from last week was
that mike mayok sent all the scouts home
to protect gruden from himself that he'd
been walking around the facility last
week bouncing ideas off of guys and
giving up secrets and then they'd have
to worry about one of those scouts
leaking it
i think so too mike i think one of the
things to realize when he sent the
scouts home
is that he already knew
who he was keeping and who he wasn't
keeping to me
you know mayok told me says hey i got
probably 75 calls or texts from
everybody around the league and my
friends and coaches saying good for you
basically uh what a non-story this is
because so many teams ask chris sims
about the year he was with the patriots
in the draft i mean bill belichick
doesn't show anybody his draft board
it's the same thing with the raiders
mike mayok is not going to show
people other than his absolutely most
trusted people uh you know he's not
going to show anybody he's not going to
show his hands so i don't think it was
all that weird what the raiders did no
i'm with you i don't think it was all
that weird either i i thought it made a
lot of sense and yeah i mean a lot of
these guys wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute you said it
was weird last week i did not mike
you're crazy i said it was totally
always freaking smart you said it was i
said i said you were weird last week yes
thank you i got confused yes you did i
am weird you're dumb and i didn't say
that last week okay
so but here's the other thing peter just
you're you know you talked about it a
little bit at the start of the hour if
kyla murray somehow wasn't you know
taken at number one did you get any
inside info about the love affair that
maybe gruden had i thought gruden would
love a kyler murray uh do you think i'm
right in that
no i hey look chris i was very open
after the scouting combine john gruden
was telling people he loves kyler murray
and so i just i always thought i always
thought right that this is going to be
something to watch now
i believe that even if he really wanted
kyler murray that mayok would have
convinced him
throttle down big boy
because we got too many holes here that
we absolutely have to fill and imagine
kyla murray had been sitting there at
four
and imagine let's just say the raiders
picked them
well you'd almost have to
at that point
get on the phone and start speed dialing
teams yeah starting with the new york
giants does anybody want
you know for either a one or maybe next
year's one does anyone want derek carr
right so it's it's just uh i think it
was just a little bit tricky and they
felt like they had too many needs to go
after murray
all right we need to take a break when
we return though now that there are a
bunch of new players who have been out
of these teams there is the challenge of
matching them with numbers and
the reality that other players wore
those numbers in the past and that may
cause some difficulties as we put new
players into old numbers we'll talk
about that very important topic when pft
live continues right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports